mimise à jour économique au Quéc
onon a fait le point sur les
fifinances publiques.
S Sur le sol objet talon annoné
dede nouvelles dépenses.
JeJe vous dis est dans le tableu
dede ce qui a été annoncé.
OuOui la croissance rôle
l'l'économie du Québec 6,5 % de
crcroissance du PIB à 2021.
EnEn 2022 ans prévoit 3,3 et
ququatre au Canada.
CÇa permet de diminuer le défict
prprévu. Cette, cinq àen 2021 et
6,6,8 milliards en 2023.
OnOn se dirige tranquillement vs
unun équilibre budgétaire.
MaMais mais on a annoncé de
nonouvelles dépenses pour des
cocoupes de moins de 400 $. Ça
totouche plus de 3 millions de
QuQuébécois. 250 $ c'est un
sesecteur vivant seul et de 100$
popour personnes seules vivant n
cocollocation.
AuAu total annoncé de nouvelles3
mimilliards. Coût de la vie mais
MaMais devrons envoyer de l'argt
dedes étudiants dans des domains
onon a besoin de main-d'oeuvuvra
sasanté, l'informatique.
AiAide aux garderies et le syste
dede santé on va dépenser près e
bobonsoir Monsieur le ministre.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Il y a des performances sa.
- - Le Québec fait des
peperformances exceptionnelles t
onon a récupéré le niveau de
crcroissance que nous avions avt
lala pandémie.; Dès le mois de
jujuin 2021.
- - Ce qui vous permet de réduie
lele déficit prévu, vous le
réréduisez de plus de 5 milliar.
- - La vous parler du déficit de
l'l'année courante, mais ce qui
esest important de dire, c'est e
l'l'ensemble du cadre financier
s's'améliore de de 6 milliards.
OnOn est en déficit suite à la
papandémie et on investit 3
mimilliards par année avec les
momoyens que la force de
l'l'économie nous donne.
- - Parlons de ces nouvelles
dédépenses vous avez annoncées,
c'c'est ce que vous allez envoyr
vovotre j'ai plus de 3 millionse
QuQuébécois, expliquez-moi.
- - C'est le crédit d'impôt
sosolidarité. Ces trois 3 millis
dede personnes qui en bénéficie,
rerevenu moyen faible revenu.
OnOn va le donner 400 $ par coue
etet 250 $ par personne vivant
seseule. C'est le prestation
exexceptionnelle.
UnUne fois en janvier 2000 pour
cocompenser la hausse du coût de
lala vie qui est réelle et les
gegens ont besoin. On vient donr
unun coup de pouce en janvier
202022.
- - Donc ce qui va arriver une
fofois.
- - Exactement prestation
exexceptionnelle.
- - Qui va arriver à Noël?
- - En janvier.
- - Un cadeau.
- - Ce n'est pas un cadeau maisn
a a eu des inflexions hors résie
fifiscale à une hausse on vient
cocompenser ça.
PlPlaisante dans l'unité familie
cocompensées en comprendre la
didifférence 33 de personnes.
- - Pour les personnes ont 10 as
etet plus vous avez une nouvelle
memesure également?
- - C'est le crédit d'impôt pour
leles personnes ont 10 ans et ps
afafin de revenu. C'est 700 000
pepersonnes. Il passe de 200 à 0
$.$.
- - Les garderies, les gens se
poposent la question. Il y a eun
trtransfert qui était promis par
lele mouvement libéral; donc pls
agagent pour les places en
gagarderie. Est-ce qu'on voit la
coconcrétisation de sa? Qu'est-e
quque ça donne de place?
- - L'entente avec le gouvernemt
féfédéral est distincte. On a eu
unune entente avec le gouvernemt
féfédéral. Les revenus vont dans
lele fond consolidé, 6,5 millias
dede fonds de cinq ans. Donc crr
leles 35 000 places et ce qui se
papassait que les places
subventionnées sont moins chères
quque les places en garderie non
susubventionnée.
OnOn augmente le crédit d'impôt
popour aider ceux qui sont en
gagarderie non subventionnée por
avavoir la neutralité jusqu'à 40
$ $ par jour.
- - Très bien. Le système de
sasanté, vous ajoutez de l'agent
égégalement et vous indiquez que
c'c'est pour aider à accélérer e
rarattrapage dans les opération.
CoConcrètement Yvon cet argent.
- - Concrètement c'est 125 000 r
eueux et qu'on doit attraper. Mn
cocollègue le ministre Dubé a
dédévoilé son plan.
CÇa se fait sur trois ans et
nonous, mon rôle c'est de lui
dodonner les moyens pour livrere
seservice et ça va coûter 800
mimillions, mais on finance 400
mimillions de ce montant avec
l'l'entente que nous avons avec
leles médecins spécialistes.
- - Pénurie de main-d'oeuvre pae
sasa vous en pas tous les jours.
VoVous prenez la voie de bourse
dadans des programmes d'études i
sosont en demande.
- - C'est un problème structurel
ququ'on doit attaquer de plusies
fafaçons.
OnOn attaque avec la formation a
didiplomation mais aussi la
rerequalification de la main-
d'd'oeuvre. Au même moment qu'oa
20200 000 pauses vacants on a 20
00000 chômeurs. On a aussi les
ététudiants étrangers les
trtravailleurs étrangers.
L'L'immigration fait partie ausi
dede la solution. C'est un
prproblème structurel est
cocomplexe. La population
vivieillissante des communes est
foforte et on l'attaque avec
plplusieurs stratégies. Notammet
popour les secteurs prioritaire:
sasanté éducation pays secteurse
gagarde. On amène des bourses àa
pepestilence connaît pour avoir
plplus de diplômés.
- - On pense que ça va marcher,
ququ'il aura beaucoup d'étudian?
- - Lorsqu'on dépense : 9
ViVilleneuve il y a su cinq ans
paparce que ça va marcher.
OnOn est conscient que c'est un
prproblème difficile, transverse
ququi implique plusieurs
miministères. Ça va créer Samson
1010 000 emplois sur cinq ans.
- - Vous dîtes que l'immigration
fafait partie de sa. On a augmeé
lele seuil cette année parce qun
n'n'avait pas pris à sa cause la
papandémie. On dit que c'est le
rarattrapage. On ne hausse pas s
seseuils mais ce que on va pas
acaccueillir plus de monde parce
ququ'il manque beaucoup de gens.
- - Ce qu'on a trouvé faire un
éqéquilibre. 50 000 semblent ête
l'l'équilibre parce qu'on n'a la
reresponsabilité de les intégreà
lala société, et en même temps a
lala demande des employeurs du
mamarché du travail.
5050 000 personnes c'est la
cacapacité d'intégration du
QuQuébec. Assas ajoute les 20 00
ququ'on n'a pas reçu l'an derni.
- - On vous a donné aussi une
auautre salle de la semaine
dedernière: c'est de tout fait
popour faire revenir les Nordiqs
àà Québec. C'est quoi le plan de
mamatch6
- - Je suis content de voir
l'l'intérêt que ça suscite toute
momonde ne parle que de ça. Il
fafaut autoriser que les gens st
inintéressés et c'est un beau
prprojet. Il faut d'abord
cocomprendre pourquoi on n'a pas
eueu une équipe d'expansions qud
VeVegas a une à une équipe. Il
fafaut comprendre et on voit des
nénégociations, des circuits sot
avavancés sur la vente des
pipingouins de Pittsburgh, avec
plplus d'un milliard de dollars.
LeLe Québec a changé. En voilà a
cacause de crédit de Québec. Ona
dedes capacités fiscales plus
grgrandes et les entreprises sot
dydynamiques. Le Québec a changé
dadans la capacité d'avoir une
éqéquipe de hoquets est-ce que e
vavais faire et quand je vais
rerencontrer Monsieur Bettman au
momois de janvier c'est de lui
didire que le gros-bec a changé
popour qu'il comprenne ce que ça
prprend.
- - Une entreprise qui est prêtà
rrôle d'entremetteur entre
MoMonsieur Péladeau et d'autres?
PaParce que Québec on imagine is
nene peuvent plus le faire seul?
- - Quebecor fait parti de la
sosolution. J'ai parlé à Monsier
PéPéladeau qu'en a fait l'annone
auau studio mais ce n'était
dedernier et c'est sûr que
QuQuebecor fait parti du groupe
ququi sera impliqué, mais on n'n
esest pas structuré la
trtransaction. On n'en est à
cocomprendre l'économique, les
éqéquipes de la ligue nationalee
hohockey et ensuite il faudra vr
cocomment ça pourrait se faire..
esest-ce que c'est une extensio,
unun transfert avec un
prpropriétaire distant, avec les
ExExpos.
- - Pas une équipe partagée?
- - J'ai rien lancé je recueille
dedes informations, je vous dis
quque le Québec et la ville de
QuQuébec particulièrement a
mamaintenant la capacité d'avoir
unune équipe l la ligue nationae
hohockey. Voyez par exemple
WiWinnipeg... si Winnipeg est ue
frfranchise profitable c'est
prprofitable au Québec.
- - Si Winnipeg peut le faire
QuQuébec peut le faire.
SiSi je comprends bien vous jour
dede rôle d'entremetteur, mais
popour quel autre groupe, quel
grgroupe peut se joindre à
MoMonsieur Péladeau6
- - prenez toutes les compagnies
pupubliques quand on regarde
l'l'indice de tous les indices e
totoutes les entreprises
ququébécoises qui sont dans cete
liliste, ce sont des compagnies
sosolides, en croissance avec de
bobons bilans. À Québec on a des
enentreprises financières. De
grgrandes qualités de grandes
cocompagnies d'assurances:
DeDesjardins et industrielle
alalliance.
LeLe Québec a changé. Le Québec
esest une économie dynamique etn
tetemps et lieu si on a besoin
d'd'un consortium pour acheter e
éqéquipe, je suis certain qu'ily
a a beaucoup d'entreprises ont
rérépondu présent.
- - Vous dit que vous êtes
susupprimé à 30 premier ministre
ququi a mis la rondelle en jeu,
jeje vous aurais jamais posé de
ququestions sur les Nordiques en
tetemps normal mes essais de vox
dadans quelle mesure c'est sérix
lala perspective d'une équipe et
ququel rôle le gouvernement allt
jojouer dans tout ça.
OnOn va sur sa. Monsieur Girard,
sisi l'économie se met à ralentr
cece que vos prévisions de
dédépenses tient la route pour
l'l'an prochain6
- - notre vision est à 4,3 %. Ms
onon est conservateur et c'est
popour ça qu'il faut avoir des
fifinances solides. Il faut être
prprêt pour faire face à des
inintempéries, pourvoi investi
popour lutter contre les champs
clclimatiques.
- - Dernière question: nouvelles
memesures environnementales j'en
aiai cherché j'en ai pas trouvé.
- - Mon collègue a présenté un
plplan quinquennal 6,5 milliards
enen cinq ans et il arrivait à
chchaque année. Ce sera obligé.
MaMais ça viendr